I'm joined today by Austin Walter who's
the co-founder of tribe were the tribe
worthy is a website that connects news
consumers so that they can work together
and review online articles with the idea
of holding the authors and the news
outlets publishing those articles
accountable this is very relevant right
now we heard of an idea that in some
ways was sort of similar from Elon Musk
there were critics of that idea there
were people praising that idea so tell
us first
Austin how does the platform work and in
practice so we have three different
products and they all work a little
differently but the main one is the
browser extension and the way that works
is that you install the browser
extension and then if you land on an
article that's already been reviewed
then a little pop-up notification shows
the rating of that article and then if
you click on it it'll open up a sidebar
which will show you specific information
about the article and how other people
reviewed it okay what are the standards
for who can review and how that review
takes place in other words can someone
with the browser extension review
articles as they go do they need to go
to the sort of tribe or the website in
order to do the reviewing talk to us
about that so yeah so the idea behind
the browser extension is that you can do
it as you go it makes it as easy as
possible so once the sidebar is open and
you've seen all the details then there's
a big button that says review and then
you can leave your review right within
the browser extension okay and what are
the mechanisms in place that prevent
sort of dogpiling
of reviews to make something appear to
be more reliable maybe than it is in
other words one of the issues that we
sometimes see is that the problem is the
perception of an articles accuracy and
if that bias comes through in terms of
who is reviewing it doesn't necessarily
seem as though
the review itself would communicate
anything new if that makes sense and how
can we avoid bias on the behalf of
reviewers so we go about that in a few
ways but before I tell you those I just
want to state that this is a serious
problem that everybody is trying to
address right now and there's no perfect
solution sure we're proposing one way
but it's not the way of course and the
other thing is that we're focusing on
trust not truth so we want to know how
people feel that the article is
trustworthy but not necessarily whether
it is in fact pure truth so is it fair
to say I mean Before we jump into the
the algorithm is it fair to say just so
that we all understand what what you are
hoping to discern and what that the tool
is not meant to discern the idea would
be identify whether a website is a
serious news website or a propaganda
disinformation or fake news website but
not to suss out for example the
particular political bias so to speak
more or less yes that that is the goal
so it's like we can't you know
fact-checking we can't rely that a
person would know exactly whether or not
one political figure actually did do a
thing sure but yeah we can know whether
or not there's a slant or there's a bias
or if a person is writing with a
specific voice and intention fair enough
so let's now get back to sort of where
we started which is what ideas do you
have as to how you can deal with what
might be the inherent bias of the
consumer votes that are choosing to vote
on a particular website so there's a few
different ways the first is that we
assign a rating to every user so the
idea behind this is that you come on our
platform everybody gets a rating
everybody's equal in that sense you have
to prove that what you're providing is
worth something so if you
leave a review and then other people you
can up down both reports review other
users if you get a lot of people that
review you negatively then your rating
goes down in addition to that we're also
looking at sort of the context around a
review if you're constantly reviewing
one thing like one outlet one news
outlet and you're constantly just giving
it really negative reviews and it's
always the same type of review well
maybe you have a bias against it but if
if it's more varied you know it's it
comes down to just looking at the
context around a review and saying does
this look a little unusual and being
unusual doesn't mean it gets removed or
anything it just makes us wait things a
little differently have you thought
about the math behind sort of how many
users you need reviewing as well as how
many reviews you need of a particular
website before the data becomes sort of
statistically significant and what I
mean by that is you know it's sort of
obvious that if one particular outlet
has been reviewed five times doesn't
really matter whether those are
trustworthy or untrustworthy reviews
that is not necessarily enough data with
which we can really make a broader
assessment what is the sort of math of
it locally so for the actual number
rating it's gonna need to be higher it's
going to need to be we have we're still
like looking into exactly how much but
probably in the range of a few hundred
you know reviews to make the number
viable but we if you look at the details
of an article the specific reasons
chosen and the actual reviews that
people have written those become useful
much much early on more early on
within the range of like five to ten
reviews because then just if one person
gives insight and that's useful how can
you prevent either corporate efforts to
influence their trust score on your
website or Russian trolls or any of the
other sort of usual suspects that would
have an interest in influencing what the
trust score is for a particular media
outlet so that's something that we are
very concerned with with focusing on
with with fixing we don't have a perfect
solution yet but one of the things we're
looking at for example is blockchain
technology is providing a possibility of
authenticating people so what we're
looking into is different avenues for
authenticating accounts so the idea is
that we make it very difficult to create
fake accounts to create unauthentic
accounts and then if a rating drops down
then that review that account isn't as
useful anymore in terms of spreading
propaganda or getting people to believe
something because the accounts already
seen as untrustworthy and it's difficult
to create a new fake one yeah I mean I
guess that has to be balanced with user
abandonment if it's too annoying to
create a new account yeah it does when
you heard Alon Musk's idea of a website
where some of the goals seem to be
similar although it seemed he must was
maybe more focused on the specific
content of articles as opposed to sort
of the general trustworthiness of a news
website in what ways is what you're
doing similar to what you on must
mentioned and in what ways is it not the
same thing I would say it's similar in
that we want to generate ratings for
articles the
authors that wrote the articles and the
news outlets that provided the ability
to publish the articles I think there is
still a general similarity in wanting to
get out whether or not there are biases
or they're trying to like get across a
point or maybe manipulate persuade
people into thinking certain ways but
with the similarities end after that
because we don't want like I said we're
not trying to pursue truth in its pure
form because you know fact-checking is
one of those things where it's hard to
do an automated way we're still like 5
to 10 years out from having that working
super well and if you're gonna do actual
fact-checking you have to have real
people doing it and that takes a lot of
time and in today's society like it
moves very quickly and then the other
thing is that I don't know you know he
threw it out as an idea I don't know
exactly what his actual greater idea was
but we don't let people actually review
the authors and outlets directly you can
only review the articles which cause and
create a cumulative rating for the
authors and outlets that way that's
another one of our techniques for making
it so that you can't just try to attack
an individual person or outlet is tribe
worthy a for-profit and if so how can
you ensure that funding sources don't
potentially interfere with the
objectivity of the ratings we are
for-profit being a non-profit makes it
very difficult to grow and expand but
you're right it does come with downsides
of making it harder to remain
unconnected from people trying to
influence the product
right one of the ways that we're trying
to consider and this is just something
that we're we're considering its its no
by no means something that we're
executing on but something that we're
thinking about is trying to go with a
model eventually like Mozilla and
Firefox's where Firefox is a for-profit
company and product and then the Mozilla
Foundation is a nonprofit that helps
direct the path that the for-profit
takes how we'll try where they make
money the revenue models that were work
that we're focusing on are so we compare
ourselves to like Yelp for news well the
way Yelp makes money is they have these
portal accounts for the restaurant
owners so that they can see in greater
depth of feedback that people are giving
are giving them on Yelp and so like
obviously anybody can just go on Yelp
and see the reviews for a restaurant but
with if you buy a business account with
Yelp then you can see more specific
analytics and then information that is
not available to the general public that
specifically is about you and your
restaurant and how you can improve and
then the other thing that lets you do is
it lets you respond back to people on
your your page well we are planning on
doing a very similar thing where we will
let a journalist claim their account and
then they will be able to respond back
to people that leave reviews on their
articles and kind of create a dialog
because the whole idea here is to
increase the dialogue the conversation
between the journalists the news outlets
and consumers so that people get you
know a better end product a better
experience they get better news very
very interesting idea we've been
speaking with Austen Walter who's the
co-founder of tribe worthy you can learn
more about it online Austin will be
following it I really appreciate you
talking to me about
this yeah thank you